Traductor: Paula Motter
Revisor: Silvina Katz
Nanahuatl, el más débil de los dioses
aztecas, enfermo y cubierto de llagas,
había sido elegido
para crear un nuevo mundo.
Anteriormente, ya hubo cuatro mundos,
cada uno regido por su propio dios Sol,
que fueron destruidos a su turno:
el primero, por jaguares;
el segundo, por los vientos;
el tercero, por lluvias de fuego;
y el cuarto, por inundaciones.
Para crear el quinto Sol,
el dios Quetzalcoatl,
o "la serpiente emplumada",
había descendido al inframundo
a rescatar los huesos
de la humanidad desaparecida,
y los roció con su propia sangre
para resucitarlos a la vida.
Pero ahora necesitaban
un mundo donde habitar,
y otro dios debía lanzarse
a la gran hoguera
para transformarse en el quinto Sol.
El dios del Sustento y el del Fuego
habían escogido a Nanahuatl para la tarea,
en tanto que el dios de la Lluvia
y el de los Cuatro Rumbos
tenían a su propio elegido:
el arrogante y opulento Tecciztecatl.
Primero, los rivales debían ayunar
cuatro días y hacer ritos de sangre.
Nanahuatl solo contaba con espinas
de cactus para verter su propia sangre
y con ramas de pino para bañarlas
en su preciada ofrenda roja.
Aun así, se propuso dar lo mejor.
Tecciztecatl, en tanto,
hizo alarde de sus riquezas,
y ofreció bellas espinas y ramas de jade
con plumas tornasoladas de quetzal
en lugar de un sacrificio de sangre.
Al cabo de los cuatro días,
la hoguera ardía con gran intensidad.
El arrogante Tecciztecatl
se acercó cuatro veces a las llamas,
y cuatro veces desistió,
dominado por el miedo.
El humilde Nanahuatl dio un paso adelante.
Los otros dioses lo pintaron de blanco
y lo cubrieron de plumas.
Sin dudarlo, se arrojó a las llamas.
Un águila con las plumas chamuscadas
se abalanzó a la hoguera,
tomó a Nanahuatl y lo llevó al cielo.
Allí, el dios y la diosa
del Sustento lo bañaron,
lo sentaron en un trono de plumas
y le ciñeron la cabeza con una cinta roja.
Inspirado por Nanahuatl,
Tecciztecatl se arrojó a la hoguera
ya extinguida, meras cenizas frías.
Un jaguar saltó al pozo, pero no pudo
llevar a Tecciztecatl al cielo.
Cuando Tecciztecatl llegó al horizonte,
una banda de diosas lo vistió con harapos.
Aun así, seguía teniendo
el mismo brillo de Nanahuatl,
pero como había demostrado
tan poca valentía y tanta arrogancia,
uno de los dioses le arrojó
un conejo sobre la cara,
que atenuó su resplandor.
Pero el quinto mundo no había
terminado de formarse.
Nanahuatl, el dios Sol, brilló
durante cuatro días seguidos
sin moverse en el cielo
como lo habían hecho sus antecesores.
En Teotihuacán, los dioses
empezaron a preocuparse.
Encomendaron al Halcón de Obsidiana
preguntarle cuál era el motivo.
Nanahuatl respondió que, así como él
se había sacrificado para ser el dios Sol,
era preciso ahora que los otros dioses
le ofrecieran su sangre
para poder desplazarse por el cielo.
Encolerizado ante el pedido,
el dios del Amanecer le arrojó una flecha.
El dios Sol se defendió y acertó
con sus flechas de plumas de quetzal
en la cara de su agresor,
y lo transformó en escarcha.
Antes de que otros
intervinieran impulsivamente,
los dioses se reunieron
para dirimir la cuestión.
Ciertamente, nadie quería
ofrecerse en sacrificio,
pero tampoco querían actuar
como el dios del Amanecer.
Por otro lado, Nanahuatl
había cumplido con su palabra
de sacrificarse por el mundo.
¿Cómo no recompensarlo
ahora con el sacrificio ajeno?
Tuvieron en cuenta
que hasta el cobarde de Tecciztecatl
había llegado a imitar
la valentía de Nanahuatl.
Por fin, cinco dioses decidieron
ofrecerse en sacrificio.
Uno a uno, el dios de la Muerte
les atravesó el corazón
con una daga de obsidiana,
y los ofreció al nuevo dios Sol.
Con el sacrificio del último dios,
el dios Quetzalcoatl reavivó
las brasas de la hoguera con su aliento
y finalmente el Sol comenzó
a desplazarse por el cielo,
que marcó así el inicio de la quinta era.
Gracias a un ser débil y poco agraciado,
cuya fortaleza inspiró a otros dioses,
el Sol hace su recorrido día a día,
y la Luna con cara de conejo
le sigue los pasos.